thank you
lovely introduction little too short for
my taste
I was somewhat surprised when I saw the
program from this evening and saw the
title of it it suggests that I'm going
to talk to you about the history of the
world from 1960 to now and I was even
more surprised that people would come to
him he talked about that this day well
but it gradually dawned on me that this
I don't know much about what's happened
in the world from 1960 to now that you
don't know so that would not be the
subject in the subject I think we we
prefer would be my history of the world
my history the world doesn't begin in
1960 or 61
that's when catch-22 was published my
history begins in 1923 when I was born
and in Coney Island thence and grew up
in Coney Island I'm going to read a few
parts of this somewhat selective
autobiography now and then the beginning
the end maybe the middle of it if you're
still here then I'll answer questions I
think it's a good idea for me to begin
by answering a few questions of your
questions before you even ask them and
the answers to those questions would be
yes and no and the questions would be
these I know I speak from experience
that I like the movie version of
catch-22 the answer was yes I did like
it did I have anything to do with it no
but I liked it more with the passage of
time particularly tonight well it's a
very serious movie of serious intentions
and when I see the movies that are
nominated the Academy Award
I think one more of the motion picture
version of catch-22 another question
somebody's going to ask me is whether
any lasting effects of this neurological
disease I suffered 1982 km race syndrome
the answer was yes too many for me the
name but among them is a fact I have
difficulty climbing steps as you saw
another is that I was left with the
hoarse voice that you're hearing and
another is that I do have tremors of my
hands
so if you notice them shaking it's not
through entirely the amount of whiskey I
drink and the amount of coffee I drink
another question be wide that I choose
to buy the memoir now alright by the
story of my life now then now can be
answered this way if I admit the 10 of
15 years ago it would have been
pretentious and if I raise another five
to ten years it would probably have been
posthumous and I want to be allowed to
talk to you about it why did I write one
at all the basic reason would be this
the honest reason is at the end of my
last novel when that was published
closing time I had no better idea for
book than this one now in closing time a
good segment of that novel perhaps half
comes right out of my background in
Coney Island there are two characters of
telling stories of their lives
separately they come from Konya and
they're very ordinary Visal eyes you
don't often find the fiction that they
went to school they went the war they
got married they brought children the
children grew up and eventually they got
old but and they were often counting
outs I was already drawing politely to a
great extent on my own experience the
precipitating reason was a humorous one
to me Christopher Buckley the novelist
the book reviewer the humorist
edits a magazine that is produced as a
supplement for for this Forbes as a
business public
Asian I don't think anyone I know
personally get slugs but yep they're up
there are people that though he had it's
a supplement that comes out four times a
years a very elegant supplement and he
made me an offer that in the words of an
old friend Mario Puzo I couldn't refuse
he wanted me to go to Rome at his
expense and eat in restaurants and
compare that experience with my memories
of eating in Rome during World War two
which was of 1944 beginning 1945 there
are few people I think who would say no
to that so I did and I wrote an article
and since I'm not particularly good at
food writing or writing in the
descriptive details much of it had to do
with my observations and recollections
since then and even even before going
into your army I wrote the piece it was
9,000 words he liked the piece but said
he could only use 3,000 whereas it's all
the room he had
so together we pared it down to that and
there I was left with something like
6,000 words 6,000 words might be nothing
for a lawyer or a politician but for
novelists like myself who takes in five
years of more to write a book it's it's
precious so rather than waste of I just
began thinking the piece originally
ended with my coming back from Italy on
a troopship eating a very good meal on a
naval vessel knowing I would get a
furlough when they came back and then I
would soon be back in Coney Island
eating the Eastern European Jewish food
that I was used to and I much prefer so
rather than waste the thoughts in those
words I just picked up there and began
with what would have been the second
chapter but it's really the first
chapter of this book and this is my
Coney Island of the past Coney Island
then
the gold ring on the carousels was made
of brass even as kids in Coney Island we
didn't believe it was the real thing by
the time we gone old enough to ride the
outside horses and reach out to grasp
the metal rings two swung toward us for
the final few rotations the carousel was
no longer enchanting and we had no deep
desire for the free ride that the last
lucky gold one awarded by then we had
nickels enough to go around again if we
want to do but we tended to spend them
on attractions that were higher and
faster more spectacular rollercoasters
and for fun
the electric bomb cause we were lucky
with the staying power of our craving
for things like pencils potato chips
jelly doughnuts and chocolate bras Mark
Twain is said to have remarked that by
the time we're tall enough to meet the
job him on the high shelf of the
cupboard we find we've lost our taste
for Jam no such wolf of fate struck me
or my friends or anything the small
family of four of which I was a youngest
not with edibles like however salted
peanuts ice cream kosher corned beef and
hot dogs or even salami sandwiches when
we found ourselves with enough cash to
obtain as much of these delicacies as we
wanted we still had hearty appetite for
them and we tended to indulge ourselves
and still though by eating as much as
sometimes more much more than we truly
did and the want but it's ice cream that
still tastes most wonderful and
delicious and evocative associations
extending backward almost of the
formation of memory itself the brands
and items won't extinct
the Dixie comes for example with their
prized photographs of cowboy movie stars
on the inside of the lid under the
transparent wax paper seal like the
evocations of the cookie to boost a
meditation
I speak soon takes me back to the age of
eight or nine and then to a family
setting which a small container is
shared with bliss by the four of us a
mother a sister a brother and me my
father had died I was by many years of
youngest in summer ice cream was
everywhere in order though and even and
went through on the black night after
then and before bedtime
the idea of ice cream might be voiced
taking on the sacramental meaning to our
small family in our small apartment four
rooms looking out on West 31st Street
near surf Avenue in Coney Island my
mother finally relaxing in front of the
radio with the rest of us if the
shopping for dinner preparing dinner
serving dinner and cleaning up in the
kitchen after dinner might say with the
Jewish intonations that she was
certainly very much welcome the taste of
a little ice cream
we had no refrigerator then no freezer
no family there then did and there would
be no ice cream in the house at that
late hour only the soda fountain in the
drugstore two blocks away was open I was
the one that would volunteer to go I
would be given a dime to bring back a
container the flavor of our unanimous
choice then was one called
golden glow' it's hard today to believe
that just half a pint of ice cream could
have been so satisfying to the four of
us but that's all as I recall that a
dime paid for more than a dime for ice
cream they couldn't bring themselves to
spend we were prudent with money because
we didn't have much but I the baby in
the family was never allowed to feel
that although the period was one of
severe economic depression everybody
sooner or later seemed able to find
employment by the time I started school
my brother 14 years older was already
working at a brokerage in Wall Street as
a customer's
my sister after graduating from high
school would eventually find herself
starting at Macy's department store be
where she would be man for something
like 40 years and I at 16 if the class
in high school
would be cutting a dashing figure in the
khaki military uniform as a part-time
messenger boy the living telegrams for
Western Union my mother who had been a
seamstress and something of a dressmaker
before a marriage worked steadily at
home at a sewing machine mending
garments and doing alterations she also
found steady work at home from laundries
turning freight collars on men's shirts
so that from the outside and that the
neck at least the church looked almost
as good as know some weekend nights
mainly Saturdays my brother would find
extra income filling in at a catering
hall for some banquet dressing up
appropriately for a suave role in the
cloakroom was one of the holes hosts
neighbors sitting outside the apartment
building singing hymn to pot in a tuxedo
or a natty summer sport jacket might be
marked he was off on a heavy date but I
know he was only going to work
Asli the neighborhood there felt safe
insula and secured to a child and ethnic
thought stronghold just about all the
parents were Jewish immigrants the
majority from Eastern Europe there was
just about no fear of violence in that
part of Coney Island where I lived and
grew up and there was practically no
crime unless one considers the peddling
of ice cream or soft things on the beach
of criminal activity the police did but
we didn't or later on approaching the
years of the war and to an extent
afterward the possession and smoking of
marijuana in the nineteen years I lived
on that Street before going into the
army I never heard of a rape
an assault or an armed robbery in our
neighborhood all of us in Coney Island
did whatever we could to earn what money
we needed and somehow everyone I know of
managed to fare pretty well the father's
all worked is it the older brothers and
sisters as soon as they had liberated
themselves from high school by
graduating almost none of us then
thought seriously about going to college
or even wanted to go what could it
afforded to them looking back I find
that something of a miracle that the
four of us of my family separately and
then dependably eventually found
ourselves for most of our lives with
enough money to satisfy our needs and
our material wants our expects our
expectations were disciplined we did not
want we could not hope to have and we
will not make bitter or envious by
knowing of people who had much more we
worked at what we could because we never
dad we had to work and we felt fortunate
indeed that we could go find work
elsewhere doing my childhood in the
world and in the country there was time
where there were violent strikes blacks
were lynched labor organizers of all the
communities were beaten jailed a bonus
army of veterans descended on Washington
DC with demands for promised payment and
were forcibly dispersed by military
units commanded by officers soon to be
honored in World War two there were no
jobs for huge and growing numbers men
stood on bread lines families were fed
in soup kitchens banks failed but
somehow we on that minut parcel of
seashore at the load of tip of book them
that was home to separate but
overlapping neighborhoods mainly of
Jewish and Italian families managed to
escape the worst of the consequences of
the stock market fish and the depression
and so it seemed that most of the nearby
districts of Brooklyn I don't know how
that happened or why we were so lucky
I do know that the prevailing sympathy
in our locality was always automatically
for all strikers and for the poor and
the downtrodden that meant we were not
Republicans chanting with us as Hoover
Hoover wah wah wah put him in the air
and ha ha ha in the torchlight parade in
November 1932 was my first political
action taken the age of 19 of 9 years
and 6 months politics is very very very
much simpler them as I think all of us
will agree even those of us whose
memories don't go back that far and far
back I can find a deeply satisfying
family episode that bonded us closely to
each other this was the time when I so
much younger than the others was
nevertheless able to cooperate with my
sister Sylvia and brother Lee to help
teach my mother sufficient English to
qualify at the vote she voted for
Roosevelt of course for Franklin Delano
Roosevelt as did everyone else in the
neighborhood and then to the office of
New York State Governor and Lady u.s.
senator for Herbert layman who possessed
the double virtue of being not only a
New Deal Democrat but a jeweler these
candidates are always one those were the
good old days when the candidates I
favored most had the best chance of
election that never happens anymore even
now it feels improbable to me that there
should have been any such curious things
back then as Jewish Republicans and
perhaps there weren't any the brass ring
seemed good as gold
now that was ended early 1930s myth 30
and today is now and things of course
have changed considerably at least
they've changed for me and the book ends
with these parables it is sometimes hard
and
to look back to take stock and to
realize to truly believe that I have
been through college that was not a
common thing in my youth as I've said
and movies about college life are very
popular and will always comedy romances
to know further that I have even thought
of colleges dating of that would have
been a lunatic fantasy at the beginning
and the know also further yet but I
studied on a scholarship at Oxford
University in England for one year at
st. Catherine's College and that after
time there in 1991 as officious and
fellow I was appointed an honorary
visiting fellow I have much to be
pleased with including myself and I am
I've wanted to succeed and I have I look
younger than my years much young I'm
going to be 95 and computer age and I'm
in reasonably good health my appetite
continues hearty it is complemented by
sterling digestive system that almost
never lets me down I still have most of
a good head of hair and probably I have
sufficient income and money to go on
living as well as I want to with enough
left of my field to please my field is I
am in love with my wife I still find
other women appealing I enjoy good many
close friendships and I've just finished
writing this book
now in between the beginning and then
between the end very very much happened
to me very much happen in the country
very much happened to the world the big
event I think from for my generation and
for those adjacent though it was World
War two the events leading up to it and
the events that followed it and the cold
war that followed which supplied most of
the attitudes that did go into the novel
catch-22 for the realistic the tales of
catch-22 I did rely on my experience as
a bombardier in the b25 squadron
stationed in Corsica and I'm going to
read a passage now that well but for
those of you familiar the book will help
explain the source of one of the themes
of catch-22 through the people find the
most gripping and that is the the
wounded tail gunner who does die these
are the facts I'm not going to read for
the novel because I know you all know it
by memory on the mission to a place
called for lava about which none of us
had ever heard about the day of my tent
named Pinkard was shot down and killed
it's a city in the Po Valley they were
several of these missions to flourish it
shortly after I arrived and they were
much more dangerous than I let myself
realize then on another mission to
Ferrara one I don't think I was on a
radio gun I didn't know it was pierced
through the middle by a wild wolf Lac
and he died moaning I was told he was
cold for my efforts of snows and
episodes of snow the novel I fused the
Navi of that tragedy with the wound to a
top gunner in my own plane on my second
mission to the city of Avignon now
except for the insertion into the novel
of the incidents I of the in center of
the the wounded gunner I the dying
gunner I actually experienced my pain on
the second mission to Avignon were very
much like those I related in fictional
form a co-pilot panicked and I thought I
was doomed by that time I
through experience that this war was
perilous and they were trying to kill me
and I also moved from the serious tone
in the briefing room and from an earlier
mission to Avignon that this target was
a dangerous one all four squads in the
group were involved flying into southern
France and a single bunch then
separating near the city the
simultaneously attacked three separate
targets that were several miles apart my
plane was in the last of the three
elements turn again and that's when he
neared the initial point from which we
were that we would begin our bomb on I
looked off into the distance to see what
was taking place with the other
formations the instant I looked like
glimpse follower from the black bears of
flak playing the formation with an
armful of fire on its wing and the
instant I spied the fire I saw the wing
break off and the plane goes over and
fall straight down like the boulder
there was no possibility of parachutes
then we made the turn toward our target
and we were in it ourselves the very
first bus of flak aimed at us with an
accurate height and that was a deadly
sign we could hear the explosions
soberly intensely I did what I had to
we all did when I observed the bomb bay
doors of the lead Bombardier opening I
opened mine when I saw his bombs begin
to go I titled the way mine when the
indicator on my dog registered that all
our bombs away I announced on the end to
come that our bombs were away when a
gunner in the way I looked down at the
bomb bay announced that the bomb bay was
clear I flipped the switch to close the
doors and then our whole formation of
six planes wrenched the way up with at
full throttle into a steep and twisting
climb and then the bottom of the plane
just seemed to drop out we were falling
and I found myself into helplessly to
the top of the Bombardier compartment
with my flak hammer squeezed against the
ceiling what I did not know was that one
of the two men at the controls the co
clouds gripped by the sudden fear that
we were about to store seized the
controls to push them forward and plug
this into a shop descent or dive that
brought us back down into the level of
the flag and though power to move not
even a finger and I believed with all my
heart and quaking so that my life was
ending and that we were going down like
the plane on fire I had witnessed
plummeting only a few minutes before I
had no time for anything but ever and
then just as suddenly we leveled out and
began to climb away again from the flag
burst and now I was flattened against
the floor trying frantically to grab
something to hold on to when there was
nothing and in another few seconds we
were clear and edging back in formation
with the rest of the planes but as I
regain balance of my ability to move I
heard in the ears of my headphones the
most unnatural and sinister of silence
sounds silence dead silence and I was
petrified again then I recognized
dangling loosely before me the jack to
my head said it had torn free from the
outlet when I [ __ ] myself back in a
shrill bedlam of voices was climbing in
my ears with a wail of all the rest
repeating on the end to come that the
bomba there wasn't answering the
Bombardier doesn't answer I'm the
Bombardier I broken immediately and I'm
all right
then go back and help them help the
gunner he's hurt
it was our top gunner who was wounded
and the station was in the front section
of the plane just behind the pilots
flight deck but so deeply over time have
the passages of the novel entrench
themselves in me that they have
attempted even now to think of the
wounded man as the radio gunner in the
rear arganda was right there on the
floor in front of me when I moved back
through the throw away from my bomb to
this compartment and so was the large
over wound in his thigh with a piece of
flag a small one
judging from the entrance wound on the
inside had blasted all the way through
I saw the open flesh was shocked I had
no choice pursue
had to do next overcoming the tremendous
wave of nauseum revulsion that was close
to paralyzing i delicately touched the
torn and bleeding leg and then after the
first touch i was able to proceed
although there was a lot of blood
pumping about I could tell from my Boy
Scout days that no artery was punctured
and thus there was no need for
tourniquet
I followed the obvious procedure with
supplies for the fans k8 kit i heavily
saw that the whole open wound was so
familiar my powder i opened and apply
the style confess maybe - enough -
frozen to cover everything injured then
i bandaged him carefully i did the same
with the small hole on the inside of his
thigh when he explained suddenly this
length was starting to hurt him I gave
my shot of morphine I may have given him
too if the first didn't serve quickly
enough to serve us both when he said he
was starting to feel cold I told them we
would soon be back on the field and it
was going to be all right
truthfully I had the slightest idea
where we was for my attention had been
totally concentrated on him with the
wounded man on board we were given
priority and landing the fight surgeon
and his medical assistants and an
ambulance were waiting to the side at
the end of the runway they took them off
my hands I might have seen the hero and
been treated as something of a small
hero for a short while but I didn't feel
like one they were trying to kill me and
I wanted to go home they were trying to
kill all of us each time I went up but
that was no consolation they were trying
to kill me they haven't succeeded yet
and so I'm here to answer questions if
you haven't thank you
if there is a procedure but I'm not sure
you understood their microphones at the
side I think and the person asking the
question should ask it I'll repeat the
question and then I'll try to answer it
hello mr. Heller um I
catch-22 has been spoken of and praised
so highly by so many for so long that
it's hard to really comment on what it's
become
it's beyond it's beyond cult it is it is
something people carry with them almost
in cherish in their in their heart and
what my question to you is what does the
book mean to you now what does the book
mean to you now you do you ever wake up
and think my god I wrote that I think
you heard the question catch-22 always
but just increasing and extend esteem
over the past 30 years many people
cherish the book and the question is
what does it mean to me now having
written the book I suppose I ever wake
up and say my god I wrote it not quite
that way but I have gone more more proud
of it as the years past and I'm less
reticent to talk about it and say so it
is say you're a very rare occurrence to
have written a novel that remains
popular with so many people in so many
countries not only popular but
meaningful to them and I could only say
I'm very proud to have done it kala
Larry to your question is how do I feel
with my foot and I read or hear so many
people using the phrase catch-22 and
their vocabulary I feel very good about
it as I said as I say in the last
paragraph I must be pleased with and of
course catch-22 is one of the things
that that's been most pleasant to me
have you if anybody has a booming voice
or wants it boom it out and have you
been back to your Coney Island at all
recently I've been back to Coney Island
two or three times in the last month ago
mainly in connection with giving
interviews to people who want to
interview me in my home setting and they
want to see the area for itself on any
of the rides I could I couldn't hear
that did you eat
have you eaten in any of them on the
side the other side uh well I go there
to eat each time I ate time I went where
did you eat or did you go on any of the
rides when you read I I can't hear I
can't say and I can't hear the big
attractions me going there in fact going
anywhere it's to eat and and I've been
there in the window when most amusing
places are closed but I arranged the
meeting place the meeting places in
front of Nathan's and I mean that you
are the two hot dogs and then I asked
for lobster roll which takes about 20
minutes to be forced to warm up and an
order of potatoes and I think if they're
frozen custard machine was open I will
have a cone of a vanilla soft ice cream
as I say I've been blessed with them
with a wonderful appetite and a good
digestive system and that's another
thing I'm proud of
I was a navigator than a bomber in
forgit at about the same time you or I
guess maybe a little earlier and I've
always thought since reading your novel
that you had not been in Corsica but had
been unfortunately I'm having trouble
hearing you and if somebody near a
microphone that working I can hear you
but I have trouble distinguishing
yourselves it comes with old age what's
the question I heard I heard the word
Corsica repeated I was a I was a
navigator and a bomber in Foggia Italy
right at the same time that you were in
Corsica right how come after reading
your novel I always thought that you're
in Folger not because of them it seems
to me I'll tell you why it seems to me
that the book that you wrote and
catch-22 maybe it's only in retrospect
was the life that I led four years in
Foggia does it feel the same way to you
about Corsica I have a confession make
first of all I know about folio and I
and you were probably in the heavy
bomber b-24 I was a big 25 in Corsica
silicon's the unit I joined had come
from the mainland sure right after the
Vesuvius erupted and and - and destroyed
I think hundreds hundreds of planes in
my war experience I did not experience
anything like catch-22 I was young it
was a noble war nobody I knew was a
really objective than fighting it and I
had no complaints about serious officers
the catch-22 structure and formulations
came from my reaction to the world after
world war ii mainly the period of the
Cold War as far as I know we operated
very efficiently my squadron so there
was a on the other hand
I do believe that the enduring relevance
of catch-22 owes its existence to the
fact that certain things and civilized
societies don't change including the
conduct of a war and I've been told more
times I can remember by people who
served in Vietnam attach 22 what seemed
to be more about that woman about their
own experiences okay if I would have
written it it would have been a history
novel did you start to think that you
wanted to be a writer could you talk a
little bit about that yes did I always
want to be a writer
even when young the answer is yes and
the thread of continuity and now and
then has to do with my growing up
wanting to be a writer and eventually
eventually becoming one I enjoyed
written assignments in elementary school
and high school mainly because I was
good at it and we like to do what we're
good at doing so even that in early high
school secondary school I was not only
writing short stories I was actually
submitting them for publication but none
were accepted and I don't have copies
ever and I hope I hope none see the
light of day but that that was my
ambition from from my early years and
igniting catch-22 I got married right
after right after the army and then had
children writing catch-22 I just
maintained a succession of jobs and did
my fiction writing in the evenings and
on weekends and I was very lucky with
catch when he told it after year so it
enabled me to leave advertising work and
concentrate on writing it is a success
story somebody interviewed me in Chicago
San Francisco I wrote a piece about how
lucky I've been all my life and he based
it on my answer to his questions I have
been very very lucky I might even stay
in Foggia with that gentleman where they
flew missions Western six or eight hours
instead of Corsica where the average
length of mission was to where they here
for three hours I'm putting my my hand
up to share my eyes in the glare it's
not that I'm afraid of being hit what
you thought of the movie what movie as I
said earlier I enjoyed the movie very
much I think more of it now with the
passage of almost 15 or 18 years even
more than that I didn't I first saw the
intentions of the people making that
movie was as serious as it could be when
the movie rights were purchased and that
was a year after publication my
assumption was that whoever made the
movie would make an easy sex comedy
because sex sex service companies were
very popular then when Mike Nichols
appeared to make the movie tried very
hard to produce a movie serious and his
earnest as a novel itself I have a
paperback copy of catch-22 and a
hardcover copy and I've always been
curious as to why the name of the
chaplain is different on the two copies
right in the first editions of catch-22
the Chapmans name was I believe Robin oh
shipment and then in the paperback it
would be Albert something's happened and
he's not the first person they asked me
why the change of name the changing
names about came about simply for this
shortly after the book was released the
letter arrived at the publisher for the
man whose name was Robert on shipment he
had been on the Faculty of Penn State
while I was there I was at I thought
it's at Penn State two years
he said he was embarrassed by the
similarity of
in there he could find though of the
Rabbitohs ship in any place and he was a
religious advisor so it was embarrassing
and he requested that we change in the
future print things in them
I had no objection to it and the
publisher had none and that's how
Shipman became to happen could you
explain the title tonight spray the
title oh I think that's an old story it
was it was catch 18 the first chapter
the novel was published in quarterly
american quarterly called new world
writing number 7 as catch 18 and for the
night I received the contract to publish
the book about three years before it was
finished so for those last three years I
the editors my agent the publicist at
the publisher were always thinking and
talking for the book is catch 18 when
the book was about to go into production
after than copy ended one of the trade
journals I think Publishers Weekly
announced the publication of a novel by
a much better known novelist of myself
Leon yours and the novel is going to be
called Mila 18 and the publishers felt
that readers would not want to be two
novels at the number 18 and if they had
to choose one they would choose his so
it was changed to 22 but we were all
quest for all of them it was tragedy for
about two or three weeks because only 18
seems to be the right number and I was
still working the cause magazine then in
the promotion department and I received
the call from my young editor then
Robert Gottlieb and he said I think I
haven't got another good title I said
what is it he said catch-22 and I was I
out the men that I said my god yes
that's just right and now catch 18 seems
very very weak and Packard
yes the winters and everybody would go
away suddenly okay I think the question
is that in Coney Island there would be a
very big change with Labor Day between
the summer crowds of the summer
activities and then because the coming
of the year it was a huge change and as
I described in this book the Chamber of
Commerce and County Harlem made an
effort to prolong the summer so after
Labor Day there was a week of what was
called Mardi Gras parades and there was
pretty much the same parade every night
but but moving people if they would New
York they would come down to be
photographed in the daily those and on
the last day there was a baby for age
which seemed so grotesque in that
collection but your mothers were just
their infants up and parade and
strollers to in some kind of way and
then it's thought the change was not
that big because the amusement section
stayed open as long as the weather was
good the food stayed stayed open and
most years we have a very mild autumn
and a mild winter so we just lifted in
through it occasionally and Nathan's was
open to all year round so we could even
as we grow up teenagers we could walk
down there and have the peace so for the
pieces when they introduce that and
there was a gradual change of season the
winters were bleak but I think the
winters are bleak everywhere except on
hat
mr. Heller one more I guess more of an
observation than a question I think a
lot of people are more familiar with
catch-22 than your novel something
happened but being one of the I guess
baby boomer is being you know 45 years
old right sort of in the middle of life
in the sense I find that so many people
are feeling in their lives at my age
that life didn't quite turn out the way
they had planned and it's strangely
enough someone had said to me a ways
back I don't know how things got this
way something happened and I thought to
myself hmm who ever heard this before
and it seems to be a marvelous metaphor
almost for what so many people are going
through because their kids are not happy
their life is not happy this is going
wrong that's going wrong and they just
want to know what happened and it's just
very interesting it's a long question
but it relates to my second novel
something happened which took 13 years
to write said catch-22 took seven years
to write it's a very different matter
from catch-22 and it deals with what
that gentleman is experiencing I hope
his experience at only temporarily
reaching a certain point in life when
that it starts to seem empty and there's
no apparent reason for it and something
happened the man is working successfully
he's a mid-level executive in an
institution that's really based on Time
magazine which was a very benevolent
institution but he's not happy his
children aren't happy his wife isn't
happy and he does not know why and the
title of something happened is very
appropriate because I don't know why
either and I didn't give any simplified
answer but that the question is raised I
believe in the second paragraph that
book on the first page it's a
first-person narrative and the narrator
says something must have happened to me
sometime to make me the way I am and
that's just what that's a statement I
think most of us can raise about our own
because our personalities no matter how
similar we are there is certain that
there are certain individual
characteristics to it and I think it's
impossible to find all those things that
went into giving us a psychology the
mentality the emotional stability of
instability that we have and that is
very much the theme of something
happened he touched on something but I
would have had been hesitant to bring up
but they says the children are unhappy
I'll get back to my own childhood
we were poor the poor they were but we
didn't feel it as I say everybody
managed to find work and everybody lived
them pretty much the same economic level
so there was no shame no stigma attached
by being less successful in the family
next door the next clock when a family
prospered they tended to move out of
Coney Island though the one whom they
was near us I had a very happy childhood
I was surprised to realize that in in
and going through my memories and from
the write this book I was at a very good
family life these are two handicaps a
novelist but I managed to Samantha my
children were brought up in Manhattan
and my dad I suppose I was living on
what might be called the middle class
level and each went to private schools
after the first exposure to public
school and had had parents very
conscious of their well-being and
welfare and I would say that neither one
had nearly as happy childhood as I did
or was although that the hundreds of
friends I had in Coney Island
growing up in that place at that time I
cannot imagine a better place to grown
up with at that time than Coney Island
at the time I did grow up and it's
independent of its independent of family
income or success a lot of it I believe
has to do with the unified culture of
the neighborhood I imagine the Italians
had the same feeling then and any other
questions do I have a favorite book or a
favorite writer yes I have two favorite
books catch-22 and
and something happened and I'm my
favorite I think they saw it happen get
enough of each other I'm gonna thinking
to move me away someplace and something
that in our sign books fear if you were
if you want me to I I do requests make
the same request you heard early if you
want to personalize inscription I'll be
happy to give it but I do hope you're
waiting through the end of the line
until the others go boy okay you've been
a wonderful audience I look forward to
speaking to you again